bloqueando todas las entradas de las
oficinas de apple daily cientos de
policías hicieron redadas y arrestaron a
cinco ejecutivos del prominente diario
pro democracia de hong kong dentro de
ellos se incluyen al director ejecutivo
y al jefe de operaciones de next digital
dueño de apple daily también tres
editores el grupo fue arrestado por
presunta conspiración para confabular
con fuerzas extranjeras un delito
tipificado en la ley nacional de
seguridad respaldada por beijing e
impuesta en la ex colonia británica
bercy
estamos hablando de una conspiración en
la que los sospechosos trataron de usar
el trabajo periodístico para
confabularse con un país extranjero o
elementos externos e imponer sanciones o
tomar actividades hostiles en contra de
hong kong o tech studies en hong kong la
policía también dijo que 2,3 millones de
dólares en activos del periódico fueron
congelados este es el primer embargo que
se ordena directamente en contra de una
compañía mediática apple daily es un
medio que combina el discurso
prodemocracia con chismes de
celebridades e investigaciones de los
es la segunda vez que las oficinas de la
publicación son allanadas lo que prende
las alarmas por el futuro de la libertad
mediática en hong kong el año pasado la
policía arrestó al fundador jean y ley
acusado de fraude y de violar la ley de
seguridad nacional la contenciosa ley
entró en vigor a finales de junio del
año pasado en respuesta a las masivas
protestas pro-democracia esta castiga a
la secesión la subversión el terrorismo
y la colusión con poderes extranjeros
hasta con cadena perpetua beijing dice
que la ley trae estabilidad pero los
oponentes aseguran que limita la
libertad de expresión y va en contra del
esquema de un país dos sistemas